what I'd like to do is create a city
government that's as beautiful as the
city that San Diego has become and we're
not gonna stop until we get that I'm San
Diego City Council member Carl DeMaio
and about a year ago I lost my sanity
and decided to take the oath of office
prior to that I was a businessman and a
government watchdog my district was
ravaged by fires catastrophic fires
twice in a four year period and so when
I ran the labor unions chose to run a
fire fighter against me a former fire
chief all of the things being equal I
probably shouldn't have won the seat
that I occupy but I walked door to door
I personally walked 15,000 873 homes we
reached each door at least twice and
when Election Day came i won by the
widest margin of any non incumbent in in
a council race
I carried 87% of Republicans 78% of
independents and I'm most proud of this
I carried 54% of Democrats so I pointed
out not only the labor costs that the
city had to reform but also some of the
corporate welfare the fact that the
general fund is on the hook for paying
for a baseball stadium right now we have
a convention center 14.5 million dollar
subsidy from the general fund again I
love tourism in San Diego it's the gift
that keeps on giving
but that gift also gives to the hotel
yours and the redevelopment areas and so
we need the industry the hotel industry
we also need the redevelopment fund to
step forward and assume the debt service
for the Convention Center I've always
said San Diego's problems have been
caused by big business and big labor
getting together and deciding hey
instead of fighting over the pie let's
just cook the books and both get a pie
out of this I would argue that the city
of San Diego has many of the attributes
of an insolvent government not able to
make ends meet
using current revenues kicking the can
down the road
restructuring using accounting gimmicks
borrowing to make ends meet not booking
full liabilities not paying for the full
liability
in the year in which their accrued
allowing your capital assets to fall
into disrepair using your remaining
assets to borrow more without a public
vote all the attributes of an
institution that does not have fiscal
health they've had a culture develop at
City Hall that doesn't treat residents
as customers and shareholders but rather
as a nuisance if you will they have a
culture at City Hall that we shouldn't
promote small businesses that small
businesses basically our ATM machines go
hit them up for a higher tax or a higher
fee don't mention the fact that 80 80
percent of our roads are deemed in
unacceptable condition forget the fact
that we have a billion dollars in
deferred maintenance debt at least if
not more forget the fact that we're
raising taxes and fees forget the fact
that services are at the lowest level
we've ever seen by golly we need a
brand-new million square foot half a
billion dollar City Hall oh by the way
did I mention we're in the biggest
commercial real estate bubble that we've
ever seen it's completely crashed we
have twenty four percent vacancy in
downtown commercial real estate and yet
city government is about to add a
million square feet of additional
inventory this is almost like the
captain of the Titanic announcing a
dinner party as the ship is going down
the city's operating deficit has a
number of angles to it the city has
rated its infrastructure accounts so
there's a deferred maintenance deficit
even if it's not on the balance sheet if
you let your streets your sidewalks your
public facilities fall into disrepair
because you're not providing for the
basic maintenance the annual operations
and maintenance costs you will have a
capital liability grow our deferred
maintenance deficit debt right now is a
1 billion dollars second we face a
pension deficit debt of two billion
dollars in climbing primarily driven by
unsustainable benefits third we face a
one point four billion dollar debt for
retiree health care city employees are
promised
free taxpayer-funded healthcare from the
time they retire until they drop dead
they're able to enter a unique pension
program called deferred retirement
option plan drop where for the past five
the last five years of their government
service they're able to draw their
salary and draw their full pension and
that full pension is deposited in a
risk-free interest bearing account that
when I took office was guaranteeing an
interest rate of seven and
three-quarters
you thought Wall Street bailouts were
bad in San Diego last year taxpayers
bailed out the retirement system for all
the market losses nearly a billion
dollars in market losses and then had to
add insult to injury had to add the 8%
interest to all those accounts three
hundred and thirty million dollars by
the way in drop accounts sitting in the
city of San Diego retirement system my
strategy for the pension is threefold
number one to renegotiate all
discretionary benefits second start
increasing employee contributions now
sharing in the cost in a more equal way
saves taxpayers money but it sets the
stage for the third reform that we need
to put in place which is we need to
infuse choice into our pension system
I've heard of a corporate buyout program
in the private sector do all employees
take the buyout no some employees say no
I'm perfectly fine continuing to get you
know the lavish benefits I know that I'm
gonna get less salary or have to
contribute more but I'm close to
retirement I'm gonna stay in the system
new hires may be vested from a legal
standpoint they're vested but they're
only two three four years into their
service they aren't here yet for thirty
years they face the prospect of higher
contributions for the next twenty six
twenty-five years they have an economic
incentive to take the buyout
it's modeled after an initiative I
qualified and got passed in 2006 that
said the city could outsource this
measure because the City Council has sat
on its hands that voter approved mandate
60% they've sat on their hands not one
job not one function in city government
has been put out for a competitive bid
so this measure is simple it says number
one you shall regularly compete city
services it requires that when you do
competition and you open the the
envelopes and compare the bids that it
be done on a level playing field
no poison pills to limit competition no
adjustment of bids to give preferences
to labor unions for example and finally
it requires transparency that all city
contracts should be posted online I'm
not interested in just outsourcing in
fact I could care less if we even
outsource one job what I am interested
in is forcing city employees to compete
to justify their labor costs in the
police department when I was shining a
light on the city's budget through our
San Diego citizens budget project we did
some cost comparisons cost calculations
taken as a function of the police
department budget auto maintenance is
the third largest function 12.5 million
dollars back in 2005 cost per vehicle
for auto maintenance this doesn't
include the vehicle it doesn't include
the cost of gas in the tank it's just
rotate the tires fixed whatever breaks
during the year cost per vehicle eight
thousand eight hundred and forty eight
dollars per year now you tell me do you
have eight thousand eight hundred forty
eight dollars per year in personal auto
maintenance costs I didn't think so and
I don't think most taxpayers would find
that acceptable this is County of San
Diego successfully outsourced its
landfill operation and trash collection
saving millions of dollars for County
taxpayers yet in the city of San Diego
we still do landfill and trash
collection using government workers and
by the way those government employees
earn $8 more net per hour than the bad
labor union contract negotiated by the
Teamsters for private trash haulers and
the Teamsters are pretty darn good
negotiators because uh we've been dubbed
Enron by the sea because of the
securities fraud that occurred because
of the large deficit in the pension
system San Diego has attracted a lot of
attention so if we're able somehow to
reform our way out of that bad situation
then perhaps we become a poster child of
success and we might see cities and
counties across the country emulate our
recovery that would be exciting for me
as someone who not only loves San Diego
but is truly interested in seeing us
reinvent and redesign government at all
levels throughout the country
to the blood can see
star curiosity